friday morning time to look at what's
trending this morning and who's trending
more
possibly than las vegas now host
mercedes martinez nobody
always trending live from the mix 941
studios this morning hey mercedes how
you doing today
you guys are trending this morning
that's is also
the k-pop super group bts they're
trending again
they were the biggest recording act in
the world in 2020
they are the first korean artist to win
the title
they came in behind taylor sloi or
actually they came in ahead of taylor
swift
drake the weeknd and billy eilish so
some
huge names on that and check this out we
are getting another look at
space jam a new legacy the sequel stars
basketball
great lebron james it's obviously about
basketball but it's also going to focus
on the relationship between lebron and
his son
space jam a new legacy hits theaters on
july 16th and you can also watch it
on hbo max john alex oh i love lebron i
can't wait to see that
all right mercedes so as if things
aren't weird enough chipotle
is now jumping into the makeup industry
what are they doing
oh my goodness this is actually it's
going to sell out just watch yes
it's probably called elf cosmetics they
launched a collection
that is more extra than its guac the
food inspired collab will feature
an eye shadow palette with 12 shades
inspired by chipotle ingredients we're
talking like the beans
and the rice and tomatoes each palette
comes with a coupon
for free chips and guac but there's more
there's also a lip plumping gloss
and it comes in red hot salsa this
collection it launches
next wednesday and like i said
it's not going to last long i guarantee
it's going to fly off shelves
i like the avocado sponge though i think
that's really cute the avocado sponge
totally it's shaped like an avocado and
then they have a little makeup bag that
looks like a tortilla
yes it's cute hey mercedes did you see a
drake dropped three new songs at
midnight have you heard him yet
yes did you listen yes i did and they're
good
of course you did this is why you guys
are trending you know i didn't
no no no drake is trending alex gets
alerts on her phone every time drake
does anything ever
in life yeah and so that's how she found
out that's how it is i'm that gold
mercedes
and who is it for you john what artist
do you get alerts about it's not about
artists it's actually about the chipotle
i wanted to make sure i got
first dibs on the corn salsa eye shadow
and luckily
i'm locked in burrito news on the hour
every hour
for langler thanks mercedes thanks for
saving
the day take care thanks have a great
weekend